We can tell when a website is built in AI and it's sloppy.
Frankly, I can tell it within a second when a site is made in cloud because they all look the same.
But I got the fix for you and it is ridiculously easy, you're at a lot of it.
Go and check out 21st.dev.
This free website has a huge repository of amazing looking designs that you can plug right in the cloud.
You can find incredible UI for navigation bars, testimonial reels,
euro sections, login pages, dashboards, pretty much any digital interface that you can imagine.
So just pick a style that you like and copy the code.
And from there, paste it into your cloud code and add it to your project.
But what's amazing is that you can give cloud the entire library of 21st.dev designs with one simple step.
That's right, 21st.dev has an mcp that connects directly to cloud.
And once you set that up, all you have to do is type slash UI in the cloud code and describe what it is that you want to build.
Then cloud can pull designs straight from 21st.dev that match your description.
Plus you can customize the code to match a different color or branding.
So guys, please quit making the AI slot when you have so many beautiful things that you can make now.
And come and design if you want to give this a go for yourself.